-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy-nominated musician
and actor you know from movies
such as "Moonlight,"
"Hidden Figures,"
and "Harriet."
She stars in "Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery,"
which begins streaming
on Netflix December 23rd.
Let's take a look.
-You're a detective, right?
-Yes. Um...
-Can you spot the other thing,
the real thing
this group has in common?
-Randi, come on.
-Oh, Lionel. Everybody knows
who Lionel works for.
That's no secret.
And we know who bankrolled
Claire's campaign.
♪♪
But when nobody --
nobody would touch Birdie
with a 10-foot pole
because she went on "Oprah"
and compared herself
to Harriet Tubman.
-In spirit.
-Please welcome back to the
show Janelle Monáe, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Resplendent as always, Janelle.
You look like a million dollars.
-It's good to see you in person.
Can I touch you? Are you real?
-It is. Last time we were here,
we Zoomed.
-We Zoomed.
-And, by the way,
you dressed up for Zoom as well,
which I really appreciated.
-I did.
Because I like you a lot.
-Well, thank you very much.
I like you a lot, as well.
And seeing you here in person
is wonderful.
And, also, I'm not the only one
who likes you a lot.
Congratulations on your Critics'
Choice Award nomination today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. I know. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, man.
-You both got
a personal nomination,
which must be so special,
but also an ensemble nomination.
-Yes.
-And Kate Hudson was here
yesterday talking about how
wonderful a group of people
this was.
It seems like it was
an incredibly fun group
of people to make a film with.
-Oh, absolutely.
Like, first of all,
they are all icons.
Kate Hudson. Come on.
Who kills it in this film.
And Daniel.
It's just been a dream role,
a dream cast.
And whenever we're all
getting celebrated together,
that always makes me feel good.
Because I got a real opportunity
to, like, make some
life-long friendships.
It felt like we were in a
theater summer camp repertoire,
and you just wanted to call home
and be like,
"Mom, don't come back
and get me.
Leave me here
for another good month."
-You did that as a kid, right?
Didn't you do sort of --
A theater campy...
-Yeah.
-And monologue camp.
What was that?
-Yes, I'm an
international thespian.
-Yes, absolutely.
-Where are all of my thespians?
-You are.
-I was always in either
a Shakespearean program.
I wrote for the Young
Playwrights' Roundtable --
short stories.
-At what age did you know
that was the path you wanted
to take -- writing, performing?
-Whew. Uh, last week.
-Okay.
-Yeah. Last week.
-Well, then, this must be
a great week of feedback, yeah.
-No, I mean, my mom -- I had
the best parents, you know.
They were working-class.
And even though
they were working,
they never missed
a talent showcase.
There never was a time
in my life
where I wasn't singing
or acting.
Like, I was always in the music.
All of it
just has felt beautiful.
Storytelling -- I think
that's been the common thread.
I love telling stories.
Through music, through fashion,
through whatever it is.
-I've really enjoyed this sort
of act with you as a performer,
not just musically,
but also, you know,
in films and television.
I knew you first as a singer,
and you first collaborated
with Ed Norton,
who's in the film,
when you were the musical guest
for his "SNL" in 2013.
-I did. Wow. My eyebrows.
Why was I --
-Your eyebrows were very good.
-I'm sorry.
I feel like they are just
very strong and arched.
But, yes, that was
the first time we met.
He was hosting.
I was musical guest.
So it's like a dream to --
-It must've been crazy
to be collaborating again.
This is, for those
who don't know, a sequel
to the wonderful film
"Knives Out."
Daniel Craig is back.
A whole new cast of characters.
A murder mystery.
You host -- True story.
You host murder-mystery parties?
-Oh, yes.
-Always?
-Mafia. Assassin.
Who plays murder-mystery
games in here?
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Like, all-out.
Family, friends. We love it.
-Now, it does not surprise me,
and I doubt it will surprise
anyone else,
that you dress up a little bit
when you host
a murder-mystery party.
-What is this?
-This is a photo.
[ Laughter ]
-That is Sir Hawthorne James.
Wow.
-Sir Hawthorne James?
And he had people over
for a murder-mystery party?
-Well, actually,
that took place in Serbia.
-Okay.
-That was a murder mystery
that Rian Johnson,
our writer-director of
"Glass Onion," invited us to.
We couldn't go out and party
and be in the streets
because of COVID.
Nobody wanted to be the actor
that, like, shut down the whole
production because you were,
you know, at a strip club
in Belgrade with no mask on.
-By the way, you know,
respect when you're in Belgrade,
you know.
It's a bummer to go,
then you come back,
and they're like,
"Did you go to the strip clubs?"
You're like, "I didn't go
to the strip clubs."
-So what we would do is we all
stayed at this hotel together,
and they would rent out
the top bar part of the hotel,
and we would have
murder-mystery parties.
We'd get drunk.
You know, we'd have fun.
-That really speaks to --
I'm very impressed
that Rian Johnson,
who continues to write these
incredibly well-constructed
murder mysteries,
and yet still has time
to put a murder mystery party
together for his cast.
-That has absolutely nothing
to do
with the murder mystery
of the film.
-I think it's very clear to me
that
if he wasn't writing
these incredible things,
he would definitely
be a murderer.
So I think we should be
very happy
that he has chosen the path.
-No, listen, Rian is --
I've wanted to work with Rian
since I saw "Looper."
-"Looper" is a great movie."
-Oh, my God, right?
And I went down this whole
rabbit hole, saw everything.
I said, "I don't care if he
calls me to do a two-second
lip gloss commercial,
I'm saying yes."
-And I hope, and by the way,
I hope by bringing it up,
people go back
and revisit "Looper."
-I really do, they should.
-So you --
It also won't surprise people,
Halloween.
These are Halloweens.
Are these all Halloweens?
-Yes, those are Halloweens.
-I mean, so --
alright, first of all,
my dad dressed up like
the white rabbit for my kids.
-What?
Let me see that.
-So he's the grandfather,
and I feel bad because I feel
like he did a really good job,
and then I'm going
to show yours.
So there's my dad.
-Aww.
-I mean, not bad, right?
-They're so cute!
-He went out, he got a clock.
But then,
there is Janelle Monáe.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's deeply, deeply unfair.
-That was cool.
Yes, this was my white rabbit,
you know,
from "Alice in Wonderland."
I had so much fun.
I'm telling you, living in L.A.,
you just have some access
to these movie people.
And I feel like my costumes
have gotten better.
It used to be Party City,
and now it's this.
-I mean, like this, they were
like, "Oh, that's Grandpa."
This, I think they would
just [bleep] their pants.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you do really
take care of L.A.
This is "Fifth Element."
Is this from --
-Yep, Diva Plavalaguna.
-That's insane.
And now is this a hard --
Do you regret this at all over
the course of the night
sort of moving around?
-[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
Okay. That was five hours...
-Okay.
-...of prosthetics sitting
in a chair.
And the first -- The head that
they gave me, it was too heavy.
So I had to have them
lift it up
as I was getting my makeup on.
And then I was like -- I
had to do a photo shoot in it.
And then I did this again
for another four hours
because I wanted
to attend parties.
And I was like -- But I cannot
have that big head
holding me down.
And so they re-created it,
made it more light.
And I went out
and I partied with it.
And it was great.
-I'm very impressed.
I mean, by the way,
that would be --
If I saw you walking in,
I've never had
a Halloween costume
that's not a zero out of 10
compared to that.
-I was like this the whole time.
[ Vocalizes ]
Like, I literally would do that
at the Halloween party.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know what's wrong
with me.
-I saved this one for last
because it's Halloween.
But it's very much
in the Christmas season.
I mean, again,
mind-blowingly good.
There you are as the Grinch.
[ Cheers ]
-That's Johnny Grinch.
-And then, are you eating?
What is that?
-What?
That's green eggs and ham.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-I mean, that's a different
book, okay?
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Like, I'm in the thick of it
right now,
so don't go crossing
your Seusses on me.
-I know, but it's Seuss.
You know, it's Seuss.
Seuss food.
-You have a Grinch idea.
-I do.
Ooh, I do.
So, first of all, those were
the lashes from Jim Carrey.
-Really?
-As Grinch.
Those were a replica
of those lashes.
I just want that to be known.
-Okay, great.
-Jim, you are the GOAT.
I do have an idea.
I think if you go on my page,
you'll see the Johnny Grinch
is like this sort of hipster.
Like, you know, vegan and
green eggs and ham or wait.
-Not a great vegan.
-No, not really a good vegan.
-[ Laughter ]
-Anyway, forget that,
forget that, forget that.
I'm off course.
But the pitch is what
if the Grinch had
an illegitimate child.
-Okay.
-Like he didn't know
that he had Johnny,
and she somehow brings him back.
-Alright.
And this is Grinch --
where does this Grinch,
where does the illegitimate
Grinch land on Christmas?
-I think that she doesn't
like Christmas.
-Yeah.
-And she starts
to uncover the why.
And then maybe they both --
he likes Christmas now, right?
-Obviously.
His heart is three times bigger.
-Exactly.
And then like somehow you go
a day in the life with her.
Like she is in college,
maybe she is in med school.
Maybe she is in a rock band.
Like she lives
this really cool life.
Like you want to hang out
with her.
She drives an electric car,
and she has to go meet her dad,
who is Jim Carrey, the Grinch.
-This seems like a drama, but --
-You think it's a drama?
Okay, yeah, you're right.
But maybe they don't
like each other.
Like she just does not like
her dad, because you left me.
-Yeah.
I also want to hear this story
about how he's like,
"I had no idea."
I'm like, "Alright, Grinch.
You lived alone in a cave.
And you're like,
'I don't know how I'm a dad.'
You know."
-Right.
-I'll tell you where he went
when he was in Belgrade.
He wasn't doing murder
mystery parties.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always so great to see you.
-Thank you, my friend.
I adore you.
-Janelle Monáe, "Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery"
begins streaming on Netflix
December 23rd.
We'll be right back
with Paul Dano.